all right members of the jury good
afternoon please be seated i hope
everyone enjoyed
their lunches
the state has some additional witnesses
this afternoon and the first witness who
will testify this afternoon the state
will seek to admit
um that
or submit that witness as an expert
so i just want to give you a charge i
know you've heard this before my opening
comments but it seemed like an opportune
time to reread that charge to you it's
not overly long on expert testimony
and this applies not only to the next
witness but perhaps another witness this
afternoon and then
likely witnesses next week
so as a general rule ladies and
gentlemen witnesses can testify only
as the facts known by them
this rule ordinarily does not permit the
opinion of a witness to be received
as evidence however
an exception to this rule exists in the
case of an expert witness
who may give his or her opinion as to
any matter
in which he or she is versed
and which is material
to the case
in legal terminology an expert witness
is a witness who has some special
knowledge
skill
experience or training that is not
possessed by the ordinary juror
and who thus may be able to provide
assistance to the jury
in understanding the evidence presented
and determine the facts in the case
in this case expert witnesses may be
called by the state and defendant and as
i said the state does intend to call
at least one and possibly two
witnesses this afternoon who they will
offer as expert witnesses
please bear in mind you are not bound by
such experts opinions
but you should consider each opinion and
give it the weight to which you deem it
is entitled
whether that be great or slight
or you may reject it in examining each
opinion you may
consider the reasons given for it if any
and you may also consider the
qualifications
and credibility of the expert
it is always
within the special function of the jury
to determine whether the facts on which
the answer or testimony of an expert is
based
actually exist
the value or weight of the evidence
strike that let me rephrase the value or
weight of the opinion of the expert is
dependent upon
and no stronger than the facts on which
it is based in other words the probative
value of the opinion will depend upon
whether from all the evidence in the
case
you find that those facts are true
you may in fact determine from the
evidence in this case
the facts that form the basis of the
opinion are true
or not true or are true in part only
and in light of such findings you should
decide
what effect such determination has upon
the weight to be given to the opinion of
the expert
your acceptance or rejection
of the expert opinion will depend
therefore to some extent on your
findings
as to the truth of the facts relied upon
the ultimate determination of whether or
not the state has proven defendant's
guilt
beyond a reasonable doubt is to be made
only by the jury
right with that charge mr shellhorn can
you call your witness please yes your
honor the state will call detective
andreas
all right detective zaharopoulos please
well detective please remain standing
place your left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand and listen to my
court clerk and minister the oath do you
throw in the presence of almighty god
that the testimony of this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes please state your name as well
your last name for the record andreas
zaharopoulos z-a
h-a-r-o-p-o-u-l-o-s
thank you
i please be seated
please keep your voice up
you don't understand a question
detective please indicate that and i'll
have counsel rephrase yes sir
mr shellhorn you have some photographs
you want to um address first that's
right judge the photos are marked as s
261
through s-269
i don't believe there's any objection to
the administ admission of those evidence
as well as s-340
and s-341
good questions
by those photographs
will be accepted into evidence by the
court
and can be displayed
to the jury during
the detective's testimony and for the
record those are
states exhibit 261-269
states exhibit 340 and 341 all entered
into evidence
please proceed mr shelton thank you
detective can you please reintroduce
yourself to the jury and tell them where
you work my name is detective andreas
zaharopoulos and i currently work for
the morris county sheriff's office
what is your current rank and assignment
i'm a detective
in the crime scene investigation unit
approximately how long have you been
assigned to that unit approximately six
years have you ever held any other
positions or assignments with the
sheriff's office yes what was that uh
when i first was hired i was assigned to
the protective services unit which is
here in the courthouse
i'm going to ask you some questions
about your qualifications
can you tell the jury about your level
of education
uh i have a bachelor's degree from the
university of rutgers
and you have any specialized training
with regard to crime scene investigation
yes what was that uh when i was first
assigned to the crime scene unit i
attended the state police uh crime scene
school which is approximately six weeks
and after that i with throughout the
years i've attended numerous courses
do you have any specialized training
with respect to shooting analysis and
reconstruction yes can you give the jury
a summary of that training i've taken
basic uh shooting reconstruction as well
as advanced shooting reconstruction so
approximately 120 hours of training
solely on shooting analysis and
reconstruction
have you ever instructed
any courses with respect to crime scene
or crime scene investigation yes
have you ever investigated any shooting
incidents during the course of your
career as a detective yes can you tell
the jury approximately how many shooting
incidents you've investigated
i have been to approximately 60 uh
different shooting incidents 30 of which
i have investigated
meaning that you were the primary
investigator correct
can you tell the jury when you say a
shooting incidents what type of
incidents
that would uh include
i've responded to anything from
accidental discharges
to
suicides
attempted homicides homicides
with
with accidental discharges being
law enforcement or of people inside
their own homes
uh can you define the term shooting
reconstruction what does that mean
it's an analysis of a shooting scene and
what are you attempting to do in that
analysis
we determined through evidence at a
scene we determined to try to find from
where a projectile was fired from what's
a projectile to the common person a
bullet
are there any principles you follow in
conducting a shooting reconstruction
will you science the scientific methods
mathematics physics to try to determine
uh a path of a projectile
are there limits on what you can
determine yes
judge at this point i would like to
offer detective zaharopoulos as an
expert in the field of shooting
reconstruction
all right council do you have any
questions as to the qualifications
you have any objection to detective
zaharopoulos being qualified as an
expert in shooting reconstruction
all right very well i've listened to the
qualifications of the detective and i do
find pursuant to rule 702 that he is an
expert witness in the area of shooting
reconstruction
based on his education and training
as well as experience in investigating
60 shooting incidents and 30 as the
primary investigator
so he is qualified as an expert and will
be allowed to render his opinion
pursuant to rule 702 of the new jersey
rules of evidence go ahead mr sheldon
thank you honor
detective when you respond to a shooting
incident
to undertake a shooting reconstruction
what type of evidence do you begin by
looking for
we look to see if there's anything
potentially casings that we might find
defects
whether it be into a window a
car
a door a house
anything like that where we can find any
type of defect
does the surface or material that's
involved with the defect have any impact
on your reconstruction yes
can you explain that well each surface
responds differently to force
if you have i would expect that a
projectile would perforate a drywall
i wouldn't expect it to go through brick
glass is another thing that projectile
could go through
are there any particular tools that you
use in conducting your reconstruction
yes can you tell the jury what some of
the tools are
typically intruder reconstruction we
utilize flight path rods
angle finders protractors lasers
what's a flight path rod it's
approximately 18 inches in length
a rod uh made out of either fiberglass
or metal that we use to put through or
into a defect to determine the flight
path or the angle of a projectile
and uh
for those people who may not remember
what a protractor is from elementary
school can you remind us it's a angle uh
it's a measuring instrument used to
measure angles
now i want to draw your attention back
to august 7th of 2019 were you working
for the sheriff's office on that day yes
were you working in your capacity as a
crime scene investigation unit detective
yes
do you remember what shift you were
working that day i believe i was working
the morning shift
with that and would that continue
through into the afternoon correct eight
to four
now how does uh in general
csi typically become involved in an
investigation we are a supporting agency
we support
and respond to any municipality within
morris county or the prosecutor's office
if they require our assistance for a
particular crime scene
is the only thing you do with as a
member of csi shooting reconstruction or
do you undertake other aspects of crime
scene investigation i have other
assignments within the unit
now specifically on august 7th of 2019
do you recall if you were made aware of
a shooting incident at 411 west mill
road in washington township yes did you
go to that address i did
do you remember approximately what time
you arrived
i believe
somewhere around three o'clock possibly
just after three
were there other members of csi present
at various times during that
investigation yes
what was your assignment or
responsibility with respect to this
investigation
my assignment was to conduct the
shooting reconstruction
as well as to utilize a video camera and
document uh the scene
how was that role or responsibility
determine
uh through our supervisors and the
different officers on scene we discussed
we got together who was going to do what
task
do you recall what the weather was like
that afternoon
uh on my
approach to the scene i was transporting
a uh our command trailer and it was
downpouring on my approach to the scene
now you mentioned uh
taking uh
video can you just explain that process
to the jury
uh typically uh our video cameras we
place an sd card inside
and then
we
or i as i approached the scene just
video uh taped the outside of the home
and then i went inside and videotaped
the interior side of the house as well
do you do that before or after taking
photos that is conducted after we take
photographs do you do the video before
or after collecting evidence before
what's the reason for that sequence
uh the purpose of video taping is just
like photography initially you want to
document the scene as is without
disturbing anything
did you actually take a video in this
case yes and after you did that did you
then turn your attention to the
shooting reconstruction yes
before i ask you questions specifically
about that did you have other
involvement in this case uh on the
following day august 8th yes can you
tell the jury briefly what your
responsibilities were on august 8th we
were requested to respond for the
prosecutor's office to photograph
uh
the home as well as the barn house for
any potential evidence
and while i was at the farmhouse i
utilized
uh metal detectors to look for casings
or one casing that we were believed to
be on scene
did you also take some photos of the
various areas you just discussed while
you were there that day correct
so taking your attention back to august
7th 2019 how did you begin your shooting
reconstruction i took my own camera and
began photographing the primary scene of
where the
shooting took place with the first
defect which was the door
can you remind the jury what you were
looking for as initial
evidence
uh i was instruct well i was advised by
detective bailey who was the crime scene
detective for csi
and locate that he had located two
projectile uh casings
on the uh paved
not paved gravel driveway and with that
i also uh had my observed the defect on
the door and that's how i determine a
start point
for my
analysis
is your role
is your focus in conducting a
reconstruction on determining who shot
the gun no
did you observe any bullet defects in
the farmhouse
in the farmhouse yes
can you tell the jury where you observe
those defects the first defect was uh on
the door
then
inside this laundry room area there was
a black mat that was hanging
there was about it was a ricochet or
a graze to it and then there was an exit
deep effect on the window behind it
did you take photos of all those defects
yes
what's the process that you go through
with uh examining each separate defect
each defect is photographed
uh then i looked at them uh one to one
with uh
ruler up against it just to get the
correct
accurate measurements of each defect
and then from there i started using the
flight path rod to determine an angle of
it
now before we discuss the specifics of
the conclusions that you reached
were you able to reach any conclusions
with respect to those bullet defects yes
what did you conclude
i concluded that the projectile and the
defect to the door was from the outside
going in
and i also determine a certain angle
up and down and left to right as to how
it entered the door
did you document those conclusions in a
report yes
and i'm going to draw your attention
to the screen
i'm going to show you what's been marked
as s-389 in evidence
detective what is s-389 a diagram of
it's a diagram of the farmhouse
and is this a fair and accurate diagram
based on your involvement in the
investigation on august 7 2019 yes
you had mentioned earlier that you
were aware
of some casings that were located
correct can you tell the jury what a
casing is
uh the casing is where from a projectile
um when you fire a weapon
the projectile the bullet exits from the
front of the barrel the casing whether
it's a semi-auto or a revolver
in a semi-auto it ejects either a
certain way and a revolver it stays
within the cylinder of the weapon
so the casing is the piece that's that's
left over after the bullet is correct
and do you see the approximate location
where those casings were found on this
diagram s389 yes can you tell the jury
where those are uh they are the square
yellow squares
uh in front of the red pickup truck
and they're labeled as mcso item number
nine and mcso item number eight correct
and does that diagram fairly and
accurately depict the area where those
casings were when you were there on that
deck i believe so yes
where was the first defect that you
indicated that you observed on the
farmhouse it was on the door by the
patio and uh where is the door on s 389
to the bottom right of the house
all right i'm going to ask you to uh
look at
s-261 what's s-261 a picture of it is
the photo of the door
and um
where was the defect on the door
it is uh to the right
middle glass pane
so to the right of that uh
the pane to the right of that piece of
paper that says notice
correct
what was the condition of the glass on
the door it had shattered
what is s262 a picture of it's a
close-up of the same window
and what is s263 a picture of it's a
close-up of the defect
and is this picture taken on the
exterior of the door exterior yes
was there any difference in the glass on
the exterior or outside of the door from
the glass on the interior or the inside
of the door there was a difference can
you explain to the jury what the
difference was uh in a shooting
especially when it comes to glass you
can determine the entrance and exit of a
defect
the
back side or the exit side of a defect
produces a cone-shaped or a crater
when the the force of the projectile
striking the glass
forces the
glass on the inside to basically shatter
outwards causing that crater and it has
a rough surface
and did that help you determine the
entrance and exit sides of the window
yes
what is x s 264 a picture of let's say
photograph of the interior launcher
and you see the bullet defect that you
were just discussing in this picture but
from the inside now correct can you
describe where it is for the jury it's
to the left now of the
uh door on the left side of the window
so between that
pink striped uh piece of fabric and the
piece of paper hanging in the middle of
the door correct
were there any other bullet defects that
you observed or located inside this road
there was one uh well it was
like a scrape or on the matting
and then the exit which is on the window
to the left
judge i don't anticipate having to ask
the detective to get up and down but
just so he can make clear where it's
hard to see on this picture where the
second defect is and you can just get
down and point it out on the two screens
sure
we're giving up on the laser pointer
we gave it a week
now you can walk over there detective
detective if i could ask you
if you could first point out where the
bullet defect is in the door
right here
okay and then if you could next point
out the approximate area where the
defect is on that mat
somewhere i forget where but it was
somewhere along this area
and can you see the defect you referred
to as the third defect in this picture
okay
judge i think everyone in there
everybody see that
all right everyone see it all right very
good everyone's nodding their heads
detective what's s265 a picture of
that is from the interior side of the
door window
an s-266 it's a close-up of the
of the defect
detective is there any significance to
the pattern
in the glass uh around the defect
uh this
uh breaking of the glass has different
fracturing
and you have
uh radial concentric and concordial
fracturing and what does that uh tell
you
the first type of fractures you get in
the shooting scene of glass is radial
fractures those are if you see
from where the opening is or the defect
itself
the lines radiating outwards
linear like straight out those are the
radial fractures they are the first
fractures that occur
when the projectile strikes glass
what about the other uh types of
fractures the other fractures that you
see basically going in almost circular
around it are the concentric
fracturing
and then just where
the uh defect
is broken right there is the concordial
fracture or the beveling
and is there any significance to those
fractures uh the concentric is just they
occur after the
uh
radial fracturing and then the
concordial is uh the smoothest or the
how the it bevels
now
what is the material to the left of the
glass in this picture that was uh the
vinyl wood combination of the paneling
of the door
and it appears to be broken in this
picture correct
were you able to determine or did that
have any significance to your
reconstruction
yes
can you explain that to the jury
uh in this situation because
the size of the defect you couldn't have
the
a perfect angle with the flight path rod
to stay in place
with however with the correlation of the
other defects i was able to get uh
the flight path of the defect
so if you only had this bullet defect by
itself would you have been able to
determine a flight path no
all right directing your attention back
to
26 s 264 you indicated there was a
defect on that black batting yes
and what is s267 a picture of that's the
ricochet of the defect as it passed
through
and can you identify it in this picture
by the location it is on the picture as
well as if there's anything to uh
identify the general area
if you see right in the middle of the
photo
there's uh the threading is slightly
disturbed
and is it discolored in any way in that
area uh it's a little bit white
i'm going to show you another angle of
that
defect is that a picture is that picture
labeled as s 268 yes can you identify an
s 268 where the bullet defect is right
there in the middle of the matting where
you see the thread sticking out slightly
what is that in the background of the
picture that's somewhat blurry that is
the exit defect and that was the window
on the other side of the room correct
now i'm showing you what's been marked
as s 264 again
uh
did you take some close-up photos of the
third defect and the the left-hand side
yes
what is s269 a picture of that is the
exit defect from the inside of the
laundry room and can you tell the jury
anything about the nature of this defect
with that you can see to the top left of
your screen you have the radial
fracturing and then you have the
concordial fracturing
when you were back at the scene on
august 8th of 2019 you said that you
took additional photographs correct
is s340 a picture you took the following
day yes
and do you see the uh area where
the bullet defect we just looked at in
the last picture is shown in this
picture yes where is it uh if you look
on the bottom where the ac unit is right
above it to the top left
window pane
and is s 341
a closer up picture of that window yes
detective i'm drawing your attention
back now to s 264.
can you describe for the jury the
process that you
did with the flight path rod using s264
to assist you so because of the the
glass that had fractured uh
i was able to get an area convergence of
the glass basically following those
lines back to where the defect entered
and from that moment that was where i
placed the rod
with the rod i had used lasers
to line up with the exit defect to get
uh the flight path of the projectile
so are you indicating that you had one
flight path rod in the door and another
one on the defect in the window no just
one was used
and you were able to line it up with the
laser correct and did the laser what did
the laser show you the the laser showed
me the
flight path of the projectile going back
as well as going forward outside of the
residence
and as far as inside the residence here
in s264
did that bullet defect in the door
match the same flight path as the bullet
defect in the window all three defects
correlated with each other
were you able to render opinions then
based on the flight path of the
projectile based on your observations at
the scene as well as your shooting
reconstruction yes
i'm showing you what's been marked as
s390 what is s390 a diagram that is a
diagram of the flight path of the
projectile
and this is an overhead uh
diagram of the flight path yes
can you tell the jury where that uh
flight path is in this picture
it is between where the first target
defect was on the door and the front of
the red pickup truck
was that
bullet defect uh at some sort of an
upward or downward angle that was on an
upward angle
meaning that which end of this line on
s390 would be lower the front of the
pickup truck and the end
where it goes into the house is higher
correct
and so what does that mean for where the
the barrel of the gun was at the time
that the gun was shot in response to the
shooting analysis the front of the
barrel was right where the near
approximately where the front of the
pickup truck was
that it started at the front of the
pickup truck correct
that you're saying that's where the gun
was at the time it was fired
the front of the muzzle yes the muzzle
of the gun was at the base of the pickup
well the trajectory of the flight path
somewhere in between the front of the
pickup truck and the door
are you able to give any opinion on the
height of the muzzle of the gun
when it was fired no and why is that
we didn't have uh
height or distance determination of any
uh
of anything to determine that
so i guess does that mean there were
certain factors that you didn't know in
this case to be able to assist you with
that correct
are you able to determine whether those
shell casings that you discussed at the
beginning
are consistent with uh or
connected to this bullet defect that you
discussed
no
why not
because with the casings you can't
determine
what type of ammunition was fired into
what created the defect
are all your opinions that you provided
today within a reasonable degree of
practical certainty yes
judge if i could just have the detective
get down and just point to specifically
what line i don't think the color is
necessarily exact there that will be all
right that's fine
so detective if you could just point out
the the line that you were indicating
was the flight path you determined based
on the bullet defense
it would be between the door
to the front
and that was at an upward angle from the
direction of the truck into the house
correct thank you judge no further
questions
cross-examination
detective uh
how many shell casings
were found at the scene two shell
casings were recovered
did you have a discussion with anyone
prior to your uh analysis
as to how many shots
were
allegedly fired
i was instruct i was advised that the
victim
had been shot twice
and then
the third one to the door
the casings that are depicted on that
diagram
agree with me that there's really
nothing you can
tell with regards to their positioning
with regards to where the shots were
fired correct
because the casings could be disturbed
prior to your arrival correct
were you advised that there were 40 50
people
at the crime scene prior to your arrival
i don't know the number but i was i knew
that there have been many people within
the crime scene prior to my arrival now
did you look for that third casing yes
no doubt when a bullet is fired
that a casing goes along with it correct
correct
but in this particular instance uh
you or any other
law enforcement person was not able to
find that third
case we were not
now
with regards to your analysis
when a bullet hits an object
the effect that that
object has on on the bullet varies with
the type of
substance it strikes correct correct
in this particular instance
the bullet struck
numerous different types of substances
correct correct
wood one
vinyl
correct
and and glass correct yes
and would you agree with me that
depending on the strength of those
particular uh items
it affects the flight path of the bullet
as it proceeds through the object they
can yes
and again
your reconstruction
based on the rods that you used
indicated that the shot was fired from a
position lower than the door correct
correct
and it was traveling
in an upward
angle
as it went through the door through the
second window in that launching room
correct correct
but is it fair to say that you can't
term determine the exact
flight path or the exact location where
a bullet was fired from
based on your analysis
it's an approximate location based on
where
the back extrapolation of it was
understood but for instance with regards
to this diagram
that bullet could have been fired
from
the front of the vehicle correct
correct
it could have been fired from
the patio area here correct it could
even be fired right here
in front of the
bush correct anywhere within that line
correct
and even when
if someone was on their back
uh firing the weapon
you can't determine
the
level
at which the
bullet was fired correct in this
situation we couldn't determine the
height
so if someone was on the ground and
fired the weapon that would be
consistent with your analysis correct it
would have had to be closer to the truck
correct
and again you indicated that
although you have
a analysis regarding this flight path
it's an estimate and it could vary
by a foot or so
depending on where the person
was either standing or on the ground
when they fired correct a small degree
of error but yes
now depending on the surface that a
bullet strikes
depends depends on
how far the bullet is projected further
correct
can you repeat that
if a bullet doesn't strike anything it
goes a certain distance correct correct
and if it does strike something
depending on what it strikes
that
lessens the distance
because it goes through a particular
type of substance correct
i can't determine the force of if that
actually has happened in this situation
but i would assume it when it strikes an
object some force is lowered
from striking an object and continuing
but in this particular instance
you have a bullet
that travels a certain distance
goes through
a window
wood
vinyl
scrapes up against a mat and then
continues through another piece of glass
correct correct
were you told that lauren cataract was
shot twice and both those bullets
exited out of the back of her body at
the time i did not know
uh
if the
bullets had exited her body or were
inside her body
well
if they did exit her body correct
they would travel
a certain distance
based on what if anything it hit as
going as it went through her body
correct correct
okay
i've
go ahead detective when you're talking
about the front of the flight path from
the front of the truck there
is that the approximate area where
you're saying that the
gun barrel could have
originated the bullet shot correct and
so that would have been on the ground
for instance here if this was under the
truck correct and then you're indicating
that along that flight path it
goes at an upward angle into the door
yes so would it be something like
what i'm doing right now with my pen the
gun would be somewhere along this
flight path going up into the side of
the the house correct
for the record i think the demonstration
is
a little bit much taller than
well it's up to the jury to determine
that's what's relevant here did i do
that precise angle that you measured
detection it was a i believe a 14 degree
angle
did you determine that with the pressure
hold on what was the 14 degree angle the
angle of the upward this one yes on the
screen correct not what mr shellhorn did
no no no no no okay just just so we're
clear all right it's 14 degree angle on
the screen very good thank you detective
detective judge thank you could someone
have been
standing
on the deck of that front porch
and
been struggling and shot the bullet
at that angle
and and created the defects that you
testified to again if it was at a 40
degree angle and i couldn't determine
height determination
nothing further all right you may step
down
thank you very much detective
for your next witness mr shellhorn
all right william stitt
hi uh left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand please listen to
my court club do you swear in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony comes to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth i do
please state your name your last name
for the record sure my name is william
stitt last name is s-t-i-t-t thank you
i'm gonna have a seat sir please keep
your voice up nice and loud so everyone
can hear you we do have jurors in the
first two rows if you don't understand
the question please indicate that
i'll have council rephrase
go ahead prosecutor thank
good you how are you good morning
um where are your current employees sir
currently i'm contracted with the morris
county sheriff's office
and what position do you hold in the
sheriff's office forensic examiner
um and how long have you been in the
present role of a forensic examiner
approximately four years
and can you generally explain your
duties um as a forensic examiner within
the sheriff's office sure i'm in charge
of the firearms identification unit of
both
case work as well as training
and uh what specific training experience
have you had prior to your work as a
forensic leader
prior to
i'm sorry could you
repeat the question prosecutor please
sure
what training experience did you have
prior to your work as a forensic
examiner your work experience in general
okay um
i was
trained in a firearms examiner
firearms instructor
i attended two
basic ballistics courses
one in fort dix the other was hosted by
the
jersey city police department i also
attended the
serial number restoration course
put on by the atf
i attended a techniques and firearms
identification
with the fbi done in quantico
several armors courses with all the big
manufacturers glock smith and wesson
h k
six hour ruger remington
um
also a trained as a knight in tech
um i'm sorry i didn't catch that as a
live and technician
can you explain that sure um neyman is
national integrated ballistics
information network they oversee ivan
ibis sorry which is the
integrated ballistics identification
system basically it's a database
what they do is they take digital images
download them into the database i mean
they can
cross-check different cases
what it does for us is it can um
relate
cases that otherwise wouldn't be
so if we have a
casing that's recovered up here we put
into the system
if the
gun was used in a different crime in a
different county different state what it
can do is it can match that for us
and prior to your work as a contractor
of the sheriff's office were you
previously a member of law enforcement
yes sir and can you describe your
longevity um in that sense
sure before that i was um employed by
the morris county sheriff's office i
retired from the morris county sheriff's
office i started in our corrections
transferred to what we call the bureau
of law enforcement worked here in courts
and transportation
did that for about two years
then i transferred to our
criminal identification section which
included our crime lab and our crime
scene
and how long are we in that role before
retiring
um approximately 19 years
all together i'm sorry all together or
all together well it's gathered 25 years
and what's your highest level of
education
masters
during the course of your career how
many firearms have you examined
i would say probably thousands between
department weapons and
casework
and how many of those examinations were
with regard to operability
probably again
over a thousand
um are you an active member of any
professional organizations other than
those you listed earlier
yes
and what are those
one is the new jersey forensic firearms
examiners association
uh afd which is the association for uh
toolmark and firearms examiners
and also
the
international law enforcement firearms
instructors
um and have you been previously
qualified as an expert in firearms
operability in the state of new jersey
yes
judges thing moves that williams
declared an expert in the field of
operation of firearms and examinations
mr bolinkos do you have any questions
relating to this witnesses
qualifications only at this point no
what do you have any objection to
mr stitt being qualified as an expert in
firearms examination
have you previously testified as an
expert in any courts in the state of new
jersey as an expert yes sir what in what
court sir
i did five times four of them were here
in superior court and one was medicine
very good under the circumstances i
won't qualify mr stitt as an expert
in firearms examination based on his um
knowledge skill and experience and
training as outlined
we will be allowed to render an expert
opinion in the area of firearms
identification
go ahead prosecutor
mr st can you explain to the jury what
it means for a firearm to be
operable that it goes back
basically
and when does it go bang specifically um
after well
specifically sure it's um after the
trigger is pressed to the rear
discharging the weapon
and can you generally give an overall
overview of a general cycle of operation
for semi-automatic
sure
each one was loaded for a semi-automatic
sure the first would be
feed
load
lock
fire
and unlock
and now
based on your last response i could
assume that there are different types of
firearms yes
and can you explain the difference
between a revolver versus a pistol sure
both of them are handguns
semi-auto what semi-automatic weapons or
pistols work a little different than
revolvers
the big difference would be for the
semi-automatic pistols it would be
loaded with a magazine
whereas the
revolver would be loaded through
okay
and can you explain what the term action
means uh with regards to firearms
i'm not sure what you mean sir um
specifically a double action single
action can you explain what those mean
and what the differences are sure if a
weapon is single action
or double action single action would be
just one action
per press of the trigger
so the amber would be back the single
action would be pressing the trigger
would release the hammer or
the firing pin
double action would be two actions so
basically that press of the trigger it
would cock the weapon and release the
firing pin
so just to clarify with a single action
firearm
the shooter would have to manually
recock that hammer
yes accurate and then pull the trigger
to release the hammer
yes
and these two type of actions can be
present in
revolvers single action revolvers and
double action revolvers correct
um can you explain the process of
loading rounds into a revolver
and before you do is there a more
technical term for rounds that you would
use uh cartridges okay um and and would
you say it's fair to say that a
cartridge is commonly referred to in the
public as a round or a bullet
yes okay
um
so can you explain the process of
loading cartridges into a revolver it
depends on the revolver
typically we see
two types
one revolver would have to be
the cylinder would have to be released
so you would hit the cylinder release
the cylinder would actually slide out
and then what you do is you'd manually
manually
load the five or six rounds whatever it
might be
so typically revolvers in your
experience are roughly five to six
rounds generally
typically
um
and what are the parts
moving back to a cartridge which is the
unexpelled round correct correct what
are the parts of a cartridge can you
explain this to the jerry sure with the
cartridge there's basically four
parts to it there'd be the shell casing
which is basically the container that
holds everything together
there would be a primer which is
basically like a
fuse if you think about it there's the
powder itself and then the projectile
moving on to um pistols specifically
um are they loaded in a different way
than the way you explained revolvers are
loaded yes and how is that done
that's done through the magazine and can
you explain what a magazine is to join
sure the magazine would be the item that
would hold the cartridges for the
automatic semi-automatic pistol
um and did the number of bullets at a
farm is capable of holding
barry from firearm too far
yes sir
now giving us a broad overview um
what's the steps of operability testing
you take procedurally when you test the
fire probability probability sure
first thing what we do is we
take it out of evidence
we bring it back to our lab first thing
we do is
photograph it overall the reason why we
photograph it to show the condition that
we received it in
then we do a
visual inspection
visual inspections just to make sure
everything looks okay nothing's bent
broken
the barrel is not obstructed anything
any safety issues that might come up
then after that what we'll do is
excuse me we will test fire
the weapon we'll take
two rounds from our supply our ammo
supply um load that weapon
and press the trigger
now you said you test fire these weapons
using ammunition from your supply
correct
yes
is that always the case yes sir
so if a farm is turned into your office
for exam and it comes with ammunition
with it you do not use that ammunition
and tests we do not okay what's the
reason for that uh more our safety
we don't know if the other ammo is
uh reloads we don't know who made them
um so it's more of a safety issue um if
they just does come in and their reloads
if we do comparisons that kind of messes
up for our comparison so we want the
loaded ammo
um now moving specifically to the case
of hands um sometime in 2019 were you
asked to examine firearms that were
collected from 411 west mill road in one
valley yes
um and do you recall what firearms you
were asked to remove during that case
sure it was a uh ruger lc9s which was a
nine millimeter semi-automatic pistol
there was a cult army 1917 revolver
a
colt mark iv
uh series 80 semi-automatic pistol
and another revolver was a frontier 22
caliber so you said there were
two pistols and two revolvers correct
thank you
um
besides the firearms themselves were any
other items turned over to you for this
examination yes sir and what were those
items
there was um
two magazines
and two spent shell casings
and did either of those magazines have
cartridges within them yes sir and those
cartridges were within the magazine when
it was turned over to your office
correct
um you have envelopes in front of you
there's one marked s-178
you see that
170 178
yes
if you need gloves there are gloves here
on the floor beside you
um i would actually then remove the uh
the magazine from the outfit
and judge once again has been entered to
events previously
yes
so
do you have that out of the envelope yes
okay um can you hold it up for the jury
certainly
and if you could just remove your top
fingers i'm sorry are there rounds
within that magazine there are okay or
cartridges rather just cartridges okay
um and is that
is the state of the magazine that you
find it before even the same way that
was turned into you uh upon your
examination yes sir okay
um and did you during your examination
document how many rounds were within
that magazine yes sir i did
and i will be showing you what's been
marked as uh s three six
you
zero
is this a uh close-up shot uh of the
magazine as it was that day and as it is
before
before we do that mr blinkist do you
have any objection to this item being
marked into evidence i don't believe
no judgment the prosecutor
i don't think that was previously
uh moved but it'll be accepted into
evidence that's item s 360. thank you
and judge also looking to move in uh s
362 um among others but right now 362.
have you spoken to mr bolenkas about
these items that you're going to move in
we've shown them all yes all right and
no objection to these
mr stick looking at what's been marked
three i'm 362. um do you see the rounds
in that picture
outside of the magazine
yes sir and those rounds were uh removed
by you during the examination correct
okay and how many rounds did you remove
from the magazine seven
and again that's how this magazine was
presented to you from the sheriff's
office as retrieved by the scene with
the rounds out with the rounds inside
yes correct
um besides the two magazines
were any other items uh examined by your
office
besides the handguns and the shell
casings celtics and so that's what i'm
referring to um
with regard to the magazines and end of
shell casings can you determine
if they were related to any farms that
you examined
these magazines and shell casings uh
separately so
can you determine based on what you see
with the magazines if they belong to any
specific farm that you examined
yes yes sir and which farm did the
magazines fall into that was the ruger
lc9
looking specific to the two shell
casings um that you examined
um
were those determined
established he looked at two shell
casings i know i know he said he looked
at shell casings but
i'm not sure we
we established a number so
set the foundation first please yes
uh mr said do you examine
how many shell casings did you examine
just examination
two okay um and before you have
envelopes on your desk that have been
previously moved into evidence um
numbers
one seven
one second
numbers s179 and one eight zero
and were those two shell casings you
have in front of you um the same as
those you've examined that day
yes
sir which firearm in particular are
these shell casings related to uh they
uh match the uh ruger lc9s
um now did you alter any reports um as a
result of your examinations yes sir
and before your two sheets of paper
should be on the table they're marked
s93 and s94
yes and do you recognize those documents
i do and what are those documents those
are my process reports
and how do you know that
um
it's signed by me
and does it fair do they both fairly and
accurately depict the reports that you
authored on september 25th and december
18th yes sir
um judge these are just marked for our
dead i want them entered into evidence
thank you
um
mr st will speak specifically to the
ruger
handgun
it should be on the corner next to you
it's been pre-marked s177
already engine devices
177 sir yes sir
and do you recognize that farmer yes
is that the same farm that you examined
on september 25th 2019
yes sir
and did you have the opportunity to
examine that particular firearm with
regards to operability
yes you recall the serial number for
that firearm i don't okay um i'd ask you
to refer to your report which is mark
s93 to refresh your recollection
i don't i don't think there's any um
objection or question that that's the
gun that was recovered in this case is
there mr belinkus
no no objection
um and during the course of your
examination that far did you take
photographs yes
and i'm going to show you what's been
pre-marked s 353 355 356 and 357
which have not been offered for you
any objection to those mr blancas
what are the numbers again sir
three five three three five five three
five six and three five seven
sure
no objection by um mr balencas those are
in evidence
mr stiff i will cycle through these
photos one by one can you explain to the
jury what you see in s353
that is the ruger lcd
um and is it fair to say that the state
you see in these pictures i was
presented to you for examination yes sir
and looking back at s353 um
is the slide block back in this picture
yes sir
and what's the significance of that
of the slide being to the rear correct
um in this case it'd just be for safety
issues
and typically when a slide is locked
back
what does that indicate to you about a
firearm
either it's
slid to the rear for safety check or
when the
weapon runs dry or
shoots up all the ammo it will or should
lock to the
rear at 356 the firearm is now removed
from the box correct
yes sir
and 355 we see the um close above the
serial number correct yes sir
um now looking at s357
um
did you describe each part of the gun
and its function
uh sure we'd start from the top uh top
section is called the slide or referred
to as the slide
what you'll see towards the rear the
side is your um
rear sights
towards the front
would be your front sight
the part sticking out at the front would
be your barrel
the bottom half would be the
would be the frame
towards the back
you see the little notch in this slide
to remember that would be your thumb
safety judge
can the mr stick come down and
demonstrate with his hands where these
parts are yeah you mean point it out on
the screen certainly
yes yes
again in the top mark this will be our
slide
the rear sight
the front side
the barrel the bottom part would be the
frame
towards the bear this would be your
thumb safety
this section here is for your slide lock
now i have the grip
the trigger
trigger guard
and in the grip would be your magazine
lock
and moving specifically to the part you
identified as a slide lock what's the
significance of that part in particular
the side lock again would be for a
safety check to slide to lock this slide
to the rear so you can do a visual shock
or again when the
firearm runs dry or fires all its
ammunition and it's empty that slide
should lock to the rear
and looking to the trigger it looks like
there's almost two triggers in this
picture can you explain why it looks
that way sure one is a trigger safety
and can you explain what that means sure
um with this back part will be your
trigger the front would be the trigger
safety
in order for that trigger to go to the
rear the first part would have to be
depressed into the trigger
and what's the purpose of that safety
it's a safe it's just so you keep it so
the trigger cannot be pulled forward
process the door
all right
um
um how do you uh load and unload this
farm particularly
this particular one um
with the magazine would have to be
loaded into magazine law
then the slide would have to be pulled
to the rear
the slide would be released and as the
slide goes forward it would load the
next
next round
and
after having pointed out the parts on
the screen you did mention there's a
safety on this gun aside from the
trigger safety is that correct yes
um and does that have any effect on
another step that may have to be taken
before the gun is fired
um it can if it's engaged yeah i should
have disengaged the safety too far the
web
ultimately as a result of your
examination was this firearm deemed to
be operable yes sir
how many cartridges or rounds can this
pistol hold at one time
this particular one has a seven round
magazine
and how many can the weapon actually
hold it would be eight
you'd be seven in the magazine
and one in the gym
can you testify this pistol
yes
um you testified earlier that shell
casings are ejected from a firearm
correctly
correct and that's after a
shock or a discharge
yes
um
with regards to empty shell casings that
are ejected is there a particular side
that they usually eject from um
typically it's to the right the right
side of the firearm
and when you say the right what
orientation are we referring to
as the shooter okay so it would be the
shooters right correct
on this particular handgun which side of
the of the gun is the injection port on
on the right side
um do you firearms we have specific
marks on shell casings when they are
fired
yes
and can you explain what markings are
typically left by a firearm on shell
casing sure typically with the um with
semi-automatic uh weapons what we're
looking for is several things they'll
leave
impressions from the firing pin
from what's called the breech face which
is the
part back
towards the rear of the slot
and chamber marks
so when the
empty casing gets extracted from the
weapon it can scratch on the walls of
the chambers and create um unique
characteristics or strya
and
after your test fires you also then have
shell casings is that correct
correct
so are you able to then compare shell
casings from your test fires the shell
casings from the ones turned into you
for examination yes
and you're able to this uh well can you
describe the process of how those are
compared
certainly um the way we do it we take
our two test fires from when we did the
operability of the weapon we'll put them
on our
comparison microscope
we will compare those looking for unique
characteristics left behind from the
weapon
we'll do our test fires first
and then we'll use the um
the casings that we've collected from
the scene
and
again you were given what's been marked
as s179 n180 for examination
yes
and we're able to determine whether
those shell casings were fired from any
particular handgun yes which one was
that
that was the um the ruger lc9
um and during the course of your
investigation or your examination rather
um you took photographs yes sir and
among those photographs are the ones
we've seen so far i'm sorry among those
photographs from the ones we've viewed
so far yes sir
and did those photographs fairly
accurately depict the photographs that
you took on september 25th 2019. yes sir
judge i'd like to admit those four
photographs
on the numbers again please sure
three five three three five six
three five five and three five seven
i thought we already moved those in
we just moved them in a few moments ago
yeah yeah they were in evidence
moving on to december 18th 2019 did you
conduct another examination yes sir
and are the farms you examined in that
time period reflecting your report which
has been pre-marked as s94 yes
and you could return the ruger box
um if you could retrieve from those pile
of boxes what's been primark s 200
already in evidence
do you recognize the farmer yes sir
is that one of the farms you examined on
december 18 2019 yes sir it is
is it fair to say
what are the parts of that gun
um
and the function of each
is it comparable to the gun that you
just explained
yes sir this is a again it's a
semi-automatic pistol
and can you hold the box up for the you
can jersey which one we're going for
sure
and how do you load and unload this
firearm
same as we discussed on the prior weapon
and was there a magazine submitted with
this firearm
yes sir there was
and how many
rounds or cartridges does that magazine
hold
this one also holds seven
did you
okay
and were any rounds submitted within
that magazine or handgun
no sorry i believe it was empty
and did you have the opportunity to
examine this farm for operability yes
sir
and was the firearm ultimately
determined to be operable no sir it was
not
what made this firearm inoperable during
a visual inspection of it it was
determined that the
pistol was missing both the
firing pin and the extractor
and i know you've mentioned firing pins
before can you explain briefly to the
jury what a fire engine is and what it
does sure uh the firing firing pin is
the part that makes contact with the
primer
the primer is kind of like the fuse
the firing pin is what strikes the
primer
and
why won't a handgun
fire without a firing pin
[Music]
contact with the primer
and during the course of your
examination of this particular gun uh
did you take photographs also yes sir
george i'd like to um
mr bennett you'll be a little while
longer on direct
yes
um it's after three now we'll take our
afternoon recess and then we'll pick up
in about uh at about 320 or so
all right thank you
[Music]
you can step down sir i think sir
just wait outside just stay down this
end all right thank you
you